toujours préoccupé par la pandémie conny
timika rooney se demandent à québec de
faire comme l'ontario est d'offrir aux
parents le choix de garder les enfants à
la maison pour qu'ils suivent des cours
à distance et en ontario
ils ont pris une approche on s'égare on
va le rendre disponible en 1 et on roule
en personne disponible aussi
puis on laisse le choix aux parents
surtout que la grand-mère maternelle
vient souvent s'occuper de ses
petits-enfants assure la garde des
enfants
lorsque je travaille et elle a une
condition qui la rend plus vulnérable
mais elle ne dit pas avec nous mais au
québec la présence en classe sera
obligatoire à la rentrée pour tous les
élèves
pour l'instant les cours à distance ne
sont offertes aux enfants qui ont une
condition médicale ou à ceux qui vivent
avec un proche qui a des ennuis de santé
et comme la mère de madame k ronis
n'habitent pas avec eux les enfants
n'ont pas accès à l'école virtuelle
le ministre doit démontrer une certaine
flexibilité
vu le contexte de pandémie pour forcer
québec à offrir des classes à distance à
tous ceux qui le souhaitent des parrains
vont déposer une requête devant la cour
supérieure
l'avocat julius grey pilote le dossier
iliad et beaucoup de parents qui ont
peur de retourner leurs enfants
physiquement à l'école dans l'état
actuel de la pandémie selon l'avocat les
parents québécois n'ont pas à choisir
entre protéger la santé de leurs proches
et le droit à l'éducation dans le
contexte de pandémie
c'est pas raisonnable de forcer les gens
à mettre les enfants dans une classe
avec 35 élèves
le ministre de l'éducation estime
qu'après de longs mois de confinement
il est crucial pour les enfants de
retourner à l'école que les interactions
avec les enseignants avec les amis
jouent un rôle important dans la
réussite scolaire ici vincent
maisonneuve radio canada montréal